Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Playtime!
Now, I've been going down the rabbit hole of these pixelated horror games,
and I don't want to miss out on any good ones, and there's a scary clown in this one,
so if you've got a fear of clowns, well, buckle up buddy,
you're about to get a butt blas-pfff.... woah.
Buckle up, buddy!
You're gonna... have some clowns. I dunno
Maybe it's not clowns... Could not be clowns.
You know? You never know with these things. I doh-oh, hi, it's clowns.
Okay. It's definitely cl- Oh, it's li- It's clowns.
Ah. Open the door and escape. Oh, it's an escape room!
"But there's a catch." Okay, all right.
I've "send" some of my friends over there. Make sure they don't see your light, ah.
Good. Why?
Off time?! What does off time mean? Hello? Honka? Why don't your nose squonk?
Why don't you squonky nose?
Aw, shooty.
"It seems to be closed." Well, why don'tcha open it, then?
Oh, if it seems to be closed use your seeming brain to make it open.
Hello? Where'd you go, clowny-boo?
I could break something with this. Why? Why could you break something with that? It's a rubber ball.
What are you gonna do with the goddamn rubber ball?
Alright, fine. Oh, I can go. Can I break you with this?
Hey. Smash! Oh.....
You're a bouncy boy, ain'tcha? Ooh, look at the bouncy boy, ookay. Goodbye then.
The fuck is the stippy steps? Okay push the bootn. (button) Don't know why push the bootn.
Uh..
Hello? Ah, good! Blood handprint... or hand person with legs!
I can't tell which. Any of these books ring a bell? Any of these books bing bong a bell bonger? Can-?  Oh hi
AHH!!
Ah, cheap jump scares, great.
I knew that I would like this game. It's right up my alley. Okay. Oh, god. I gotta go through this bill--
Let me pick up your baby here and drop him off into the abyss of forever. Push that button and take this bell.
Can I break your face?
*glass shatters*
Whoa!
Didn't expect that to do nothin'. I got a toy knife.
I've seen s-- oh.
You're still talking somehow. I don't...
Uh-oh, that's a bad sound.
Okay, so I don't know how to make them not see my light.
Oohkay, hello. *balloon pops*
Ooh hi, okay. I got a candle.
Uhh, maybe it has something inside.
Toy knife on that?
Well, the crows were appreciative of that maneuver!
Oh, hi! I saw something!
Ooh, hi.. Okay!
I don't know why I did that! Okay, hi- no, NO!
Awwwwhhh...
Shitty tits. Hi, buddy. How you doing? Shit.
Okay. So, I think I know what I gotta do.
This is gonna be a relatively simple game.
Hey, take some of this in your face right now!
Ha-boink! Gimme that.
I'll take you, move you, push that.
What's with the scratchies on the... is that nothin'?
Probably a whole lot of no--
*gasp* Aiiiiii!
*balloon pops*
Kay, that was weird.
Why- wwAAAHHH, NO-
Is there a way to like, turn off the flashlight, so I don't have to...
deal with, uh...
*glass shatters*
Is there way to turn that off? Off time??
There's got to be a way to turn that off, right?
Well, just gonna have to persevere, like the badass that I is.
Hope for the beyayayust.(best)
I do that a lot. I hope.
Let's just go. Urgh, I don't know, I don't, I didn't see nothing.
Oh, okay. Bye then. You need a key, missing a handle.
Uggghh.
Oh, SHIT!
God, what do I do?!
OH, I'm DOUBLE dead! Ohhh, gooood! Twoooo!!
I don't know how to-
Space!
Ahhh....
I only get a certain amount of off time?!
I only a certain amount of off time?!?
Well, ain't that a bunch of bonkey bunkerrrrr....
No one told me that I needed to press spa--  oh, hi buddy..
Goodbye. See you then. Alright, fare thee well.
*balloon pops*
Go have luck on your adventures...
Yee...
Slash, poink. Okay, turn off.
Kay, that appeared, nothing in the cabinets. Missing a handle? How about a candle for the handle?
Okay, fine then. Alright.
How about a candle for the box. No?
Okay, how about a candle light, oh, lit the candle on fire, okay. That's good.
I don't know what that did..
OOoohh....
Didn't see no clown. Doh-- Nope! No clowns here. Need a candle? Candle?
Hm.
Missing a handle? Candle for the handle? Handle candle!
Candle handle bandle gamble! Put the candle in the handle!
Burn the bookshelf down! Burn the infidels!...
What? Oh, hi.
Do you need a candle? Can I give you a candle? Who needs a candle? I got a lit candle here.
It's purdy lit, if you ask me.
Blood? Candle?
You need blood candle?
Oohh! Hi, buddy. Okay. Scuse me, I'mma skedaddle.
Oh! Hi, okay. I burned the box. I got a handle, this makes-
Ohhhh...
This makes logical sense.
UWAOH!
Is that a super soaker? It's a super soaker! Get sploo- oh, he's gone.
I was gonna sploosh him real good. All right, who wants to get splooooshed?
I got a sploosher gun. It's got full of sploosh jui- lies? Well better clean up that mess. Nope.
It's just gonna be there reminding me of my failures. Sploosh!
Ooohhh!
Gotta key!
HEY!
I thought I was deeaaaad.
Thought I was Dream Daddy.
Okay, need a key. Oh, hi. I didn't even notice you on the first pass.
Why didn't I notice that?
Hello? Okay.
I've found another key. Is this one for the door?
Oh, hi. Hello friend.
How are you doing? Goodbye, gonna keep going, in the darkness.
Oh, I better turn this back on because that's important. Can't see otherwise, boink. Yayy!
Yayy!! Did I dones it?
Ooh, that's it then, okay!
Well, no fantastic outro for me, then.
Either way, that was Playtime.
That was a short experience, but it was...
That was good! I love, I-I...
I actually really liked those, uh, those point-and-click style adventures.
Especially when they're in the pixelated style, because they remind me of Deep Sleep.
And the Deep Sleep series.
Now, that was a great point-and-click, like, adventure game.
I love those. It was terrifying and amazing.
And if you haven't seen those yet, I'll put those links in the description below.
But this reminded me of that. So the developer, yes I'm good here, clowns are scary.
Eh, not too bad a mechanic either,
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
And let me know what you thought down in the comments below.
And as always, I will see you....
In the next video!
Buh-bye!!
| Outro Song: Shurk - Haunted |